♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est sûr que ma mère
me prenait pas au sérieux,
personne me prend au sérieux
dans tout ça.
- Dans le sous-sol de
ses parents, Badr Chobar
s'active. Le cégepien observe
le cours de différentes
cryptomonnaies.
BADR CHOBAR, cégeptien
- C'est virtuel, ça n'existe pas
donc c'est nouveau pour eux.
- En un clic, il étoffe
son portfolio avec un objectif
clair derrière la tête.
- Pourqum'm'm'm'intéresse?
Parce que je veux être libre
financièrement. Je ne veux pas
travailler toute ma vie,
avdededededettes toute ma vie.
Je veux vraiment pouvoir
atteindre mes objectifs.
- C'est grâce aux réseauxauauaué
à investir. Sur TikTok,
il suit des influenceurs
qui se décrivent comme
des coachs en finance.
- Tu achètes une propriété
400 000 $.
- Parmi eux, le Montréalais
Issa Mbaye. Il y a deux ans,
le trentenaire n'était pas
du tout actif sur les réseaux
sociaux. Pendant la pandémie,
il commence à filmer
des capsules et
s'étonne de leur succès.
ISSA MBAYE,
créateurenenenenenu
- À chaque fois qu'il doit faire
un achat ou une transaction,
il va récupérer toutes
les économies qu'il a mises
MaMaMaMaMaMais, lorsque j'ai
partagé mon contenu sur TikTok
et que j'ai pu l'adapter
à la réalité, écoute, c'était
explosif! Et c'est là que j'aias
sont intéressés à l'information.
- Quand je vois ça, je pense
à... ça t'amène à... plus
à la liberté financière.
- Tu as dit quoi, liberté?
- Oui, liberté financière.
- La liberté financière.
- Pour vulgariser la finance,
Issa demande l'aide de
sa soeur, âgée de 18 ans.
- Tu penses que les gens
vont être intéressés comme ça?
- Oui parce que je pense que...
comme "live", le décor, c'est
un peu trop formel et tout.
- Comme plusieurs de ses amis,
elle a déjà commencé à acheter
ses premières actions.
Pour Issa, c'est signe que
les jeunes ont un rapport
différent avec l'investissement.
- On entend toujours cette même
phrase, le 9 à 5, OK, prendre
sa retraite à 65 ans, mettre
de l'argent à côté pour
ses REER. Moi, je te dirais
qu'aujourd'hui, ce que
nos parents voulaient,
ce que nous, on veut
aujourd'hui, c'est deux choses
complètement différentes.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Issa n'est pas seul à avoir
identifié ce nouveau paradigme.
Sur TikTok, ils sont des
centaines à faire des finances
personnelles leur niche.
Bourse, crypto, immobilier,
placem
- En voici un qui explique
l'idée : en bourse,
ça s'appelle... S&P 500...
- Le langage de la finance
n'a jamais été aussi populaire.
- Et n'oublie pas d'utiliser
TikTok comme marketing.
- Tedia Rosarion fait
aussi partie de ces nouveaux
influenceurs. La diplômée
en comptabilité a quitté
son emploi dans une banque
il y a deux ans.
Depuis, elle vit uniquement
de la création de contenus.
TEDIA ROSARION,
créatrice de contenu
- Je me souviens, au début,
ma mère était comme :u u u u u ,
de cheveux, de ci, de ça;
ça va pas marcher de
parler de finances".
Finalement, ça se passe bien
à date pour moi.
(rire)
- Le nombre d'abonnés de Tedia
est en croissance constante,
mais l'engouement n'est pas
seulement virtuel. Dans sa vie
de tous les jours aussi,
la jeune femme le constate.
- J'ai mon père maintenant
aussi qui s'est planifié
sa retraite par lui-même
avec ses investissements.
J'ai ma petite soeur, qui est
comme : "J'ai acheté ma première
action." J'ai mes amis, genre,
tout le monde... Je pense
que ça va être dans la vie
de tout le monde, à 100 %,
parce que c'est tellement
rendu accessible.
- Il est vrai que l'accès à
l'investissement n'a jamais été
aussi facile. Les applications
comme WealthSimple permettent
d'acheter des
en quelques secondes
et leur popularité
a grimpé en flèche dans
les deux dernières années.
- La barrière à l'entrée est
nettement moins importante
qu'elle l'aurait été pour
des générations antérieures.
- Le professeur Simon Dermarkar
voit ce virage d'un bon oeil.
Pour l'expert on assiste
à une démocratisation
de la finance.
SIMON DERMARKAR, prof. Dép. de
sciences comptables HEC Montréal
- Il y a un sentiment
d'appartenance à des
communautés, il y a
un sentiment de développement
des connaissances dans une
industrie dont plusieurs
ignorent carrément son
existence. Et ça, je crois que
c'est quelque chose de positif.
- Moi, ce qui m'inquiète,
c'est le sentiment que faire
de l'argent, c'est facile.
- Mais les risques
sont nombreux, prévient
l'Autorité des marchés
financiers du Québec.
Me LOUIS MORISSET, PDG, Autorité
des marchés financiers du Québec
- On est aux prises avec
un marché qui est très volatile.
Il y a des gens qui vont
investir dans le creux de vague,
tant mieux, mais ceux qui
investissent au sommet
de la vague pourraient
évidemment se faire mal.
- Au-delà des risques associés
à la volatilité de certains
investissements, le PDG de l'AMF
s'inquiète du message propagé
par beaucoup d'influenceurs.
- Encore une fois, il y a
cette perception-là qu'on peut
tout faire seul et puis
qu'on est en mesure de prendre
de bonnes décisions seul.
Je pense que l'avenir nous dira
que... il y en a qui se seront
trompés royalement là-dedans.
- Oui, j'ai fait de l'argent,
mais j'ai perdu de l'argent
aussi, donc...
- Badr Chobar est conscient de
ces risques; lorsqu'il était
secondaire l'étudiant a perdu
2000 $ après l'effondrement
d'une cryptomonnaie.
La mésaventure ne l'a
cependant pas arrêté; l'appât
du gain est resté trop fort.
- Ce n'est pas la première fois
que j'ai perdu de l'argent dans
ce milieu, donc moi, je suis
habitué. Il faut pas avoir
peur de perdre. Je sais pas
comment l'expliquer....
perdre 2000 $ dans ce milieu,
pour moi, c'est correct.
J'ai pas de sentiments.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Si le cégepien
rêve de vivre, un jour,
de ses investissements, il n'a
pas l'intention d'abandonner
les études pour autant.
Signe que les promesses
de gains rapides ne font
pas disparaître les besoins
immédiats : celui de trouver
un emploi, de payer ses factures
en attendant de, peut-être
un jour, toucher le gros lot.